i have three thousand eighty subs so do
i play all of them
in like a tag you suggesting do play all
of them in a 24 hour stream
i feel like that would take a month to
finish
but maybe not i don't know also leech
ass only allows for
i think the maximum is a hundred percent
simul
which i think i saw mark asserman do at
some point
let's play a spanish there's got to be
at least a few
few people who play the roy lopez in the
chat
right so 97
is a move
having some vague memories of
d4 takes in the knight d5
i'm just kind of making stuff up here
but it looks interesting
let me take this
looks really interesting
i'm out of theory but oh wait there's
two attackers
huh so i've
a couple of things hanging here but my
opponents appears to be baffled
so that's nice
um i have a feeling we're going into
like some
some sort of theory this might be a trap
there's a line in the english that this
reminds me of
which i might have to show after the
game
but i do like the fact my opponent's
thinking because it takes
i can take here and then take on e7
winning back the piece hopefully with a
good position
i can take the bishop my queen
i think it's already winning for white
though like regardless of whether
block takes yeah this is kind of what i
was hoping for
so yeah black realized
and now this is where the real beauty
strikes
my queen again
now when you discover check the piece
that's doing the check
could potentially be taken um
i'll try and explain all of this after
the game
um but okay we're going to see the the
nice finish
oh so nice i haven't had
something like that in a long time
um so this was not
this was not opening preparation in the
spanish
but this was opening preparation from an
english opening
which i'll have to maybe explain
oh also gary's suggesting a nice uh nice
idea
um wait
except i think gary's suggesting a not a
nice idea
um also steven gray thanks for the 15
dollars
uh gary's saying queen f6 which i don't
think
works because then the king has a safe
score on f8
um so if f6 were played i would take
with the bishop
and this is force mate because here it's
mate and if here
this is mate um
yeah no need to be sorry it would have
been tragic to like
to get to this position black plays f6
and then i
i play this and then end up losing
um so a few years ago
i gave a lecture uh at the st louis
chess club
about an opening i think the lecture was
called something like
um like my favorite miniatures
and there is a game between karjakin
and andreikin i believe starting from in
english
uh we'll see if we can find it in the
database
well it was this line so even though
this was completely different opening it
reached like a very similar situation
um i think andreikin was was white
but we'll see okay so this is like a
kind of main line
the knight d5 was played here we go
yeah i'm draking karjakin and
um karjakin lost in 10 moves
and just watch how karjakin lost it's
almost identical to what just happened
so bishop g7 bishop g5
and then knight takes so the same exact
tactical sequence
karyakin took on d4 because the knight
is kind of tied down to e7
and then queen take d4 decision ever oh
thank you so much
scrawl elite
vampire chicken in the chat maybe has a
link
that wasn't my yeah it wasn't my game it
was uh
these are two super gms
hey here it is yeah this is a
a blast from the past so
if people want to watch it the link is
in the chat
um yeah i think it's vampire chicken
so this is one of my like my favorite
gm miniatures because karjakin 2700
losing so quickly to this like queen
sack
karjakin also castled and then it was
the same
like mating sequence he just resigned in
this position
so um that was fun
so that will go on youtube um
actually i think i have
i think i shared a video about this this
exact game too on my own channel
at some point um
but of course like that it was from an
english so this was a spanish
d4
oh wow so this trap still kind of exists
does knight take d4 yeah so this
uh this was all probably still fine play
from white
and queen takes d4 is the only move here
that works
i should explain if knight takes d4 here
at first it looks like i can just win
the queen but
even better is made in two
oh you have to go well thanks for
stopping by thanks for all the support
ranka is java and
hello to youtube uh follow on twitch
if you want to watch these sort of
things happen in real time